Hollywood legend Mickey Rooney has died aged 93 after battling a long illness.
The actor, whose film and musical career spanned nine decades,...
...was best known for his boy next door role in the Andy Hardy movies...
...and earned an Oscar nomination at just 19 years old.
He was also nominated for four Academy Awards and received two special Oscars,...
...including one in 1983 for his body of work.
Rooney starred alongside Judy Garland in four films, including Breakfast at Tiffany's...
...and enjoyed international success alongside Elizabeth Taylor...
...for 1944 movie National Velvet.
Later in life, he took to the stage.
Why is it?
I'll explain this.
In America, we have no panto.
When they cast it, and they called us to be here,...
...without a doubt we said what an opportunity for Jan and myself.
The show business legend who married eight times,...
...continued to work in film, television and theatre well into his 80s...
...and said that enjoying what he did kept him going.